from more superhero movies to down to
earth dramas and everything in between
here are all the movies that are set to
blow you away in summer of 2019.
kicking off summer on may 31st is
godzilla king of the monsters
the follow-up to the well-received 2014
movie about the legendary kaiju
the movie is the third installment in
legendary entertainment's monsterverse
following up on 2017's kong skull island
and setting up an eventual battle
between the two monsters in 2020's
godzilla vs
kong this island is just the beginning
there's more out there what do you mean
more this world never belonged to us it
belonged to them
hopefully that movie can live up to what
we got the last time godzilla and king
kong threw down
on top of bringing back characters from
the 2014 godzilla the sequel is bringing
in a roster of fan favorite actors
including stranger things millie bobby
brown
bates motels vera farmiga and friday
night lights kyle chandler
together they play a family swept up in
the crisis that the monsters of the
title cause
adding a human element to what promises
to be a larger than life slugfest
coming out on june 7th is long shot a
big screen comedy team up starring seth
rogen and charlize theron
it comes from a script by the interview
writer dan sterling which made the
blacklist collection of hottest
unproduced screenplays in 2011.
the movie stars rogan as an out-of-work
journalist named fred flarsky who after
getting fed up with his bad luck in
self-destructive ways
decides he's going to finally pursue his
longtime crush
a former babysitter from his childhood
the only problem
she's since become one of the most
powerful women in the world
as well as a presidential candidate will
he succeed in winning her affections
we don't know but it'll probably be
funny to see him try
sony is bringing back the men in black
series with a new spin-off on june 14th
the latest take on the comic book
adaptation will take the series beyond
the bounds of new york city
telling a story on a more global scale
subbing for tommy lee jones will smith
and josh brolin this time will be
thor ragnarok co-stars chris hemsworth
and tessa thompson
they'll be joined in the cast by emma
thompson no relation who's returning to
her role as the mib
chief agent o thanks to their shared
screen time in the marvel universe
we know the two leads have great
chemistry but the movie will reportedly
focus on not just them
but a whole ensemble of characters
building out the super secret
organization with a cast of fresh faces
it's all being brought to life by fate
of the furious director
f gary gray who's teased that
international will take the series to a
fresh new place while still staying true
to the movies that came before it
the men in black aren't the only cool
calm and collected characters coming
back on june 14th
there's also a new movie about shaft you
know they say that cat shaft is one
bad mother shut up you guys what's going
on
we're just talking about shaw i can dig
it the film has been described as a
direct sequel to the shaft movie from
2000 which starred samuel l jackson as
john shaft
ii nephew of the original shaft played
by richard rountree
in keeping with that tradition the new
movie will focus on john shaft iii
an fbi agent and cyber security expert
played by jesse t
usher both roundtree and jackson are
making appearances in the new movie
which will see three generations of
shaft teaming up to crack a mystery
it sounds like more style than one movie
can handle
for american audiences shaft will be
getting a full theatrical rollout
but viewers outside the country will be
able to see it on netflix on june 28th
31 years after the original child's play
first gave him life
chucky's coming back to the big screen
on june 21st
after seven movies in the same
continuity the original story is finally
getting the remake treatment
this time without the involvement of
creator don mancini or
long-time chucky voice actor brad dorf
on top of a new creative team the remake
also features a deeply unsettling
redesign for the series iconic
good guys doll which will be called a
buddy doll in the new film
adding a new level of wide-eyed
innocence to the serial killer possessed
toy hi
i'm chucky wanna play the conjuring
cinematic universe continues to grow
with a third entry in the annabelle
series promising that 2019 will be a
banner year for horror movies about
creepy dolls
the new installment is a follow-up to
the 2017 prequel annabelle creation
and is set for release on july 3rd the
new movie will bring the series forward
in time to the conjuring territory with
appearances from patrick wilson
and vera farmiga's ed and lorraine
warren who eventually end up in
possession of the haunted doll
where's the doll now someplace safe
the story for the sequel has been
described as annabelle meets night at
the museum
it'll feature the haunted doll exerting
its twisted influence inside of the
warren's cluttered artifact room
bringing evil to life to terrorize the
couple's young daughter and her
babysitters
in other words it's time for the
warren's kid to take up the family
business of hunting demons this summer
whether she's ready for the job or not
tom holland's spider-man is set to
continue his adventures in the marvel
cinematic universe with a second
standalone film on july 5th
2019. after taking some detours with the
avengers and
getting killed for a little while the
new movie will take the web slinger back
to basics with another hit of action
comedy from the creative team behind
spider-man homecoming
despite the familiarity behind the
scenes the new spider-man adventure will
feel different from all the characters
previous movies
taking him outside of his queen's
neighborhood and across the ocean to
europe
while he's there he'll face off with the
villainous mysterio
a trickster character from marvel comics
being brought into live action for the
first time
fishbowl and all by jake gyllenhaal
we've all had our share of uber horror
stories the driver goes the long way
around the city to the airport and you
almost miss your flight
takes one too many back road shortcuts
and gets completely lost thus sending
you spiraling into a mini meltdown in
the back seat
or asks way too many questions that you
weren't prepared to answer after dancing
and drinking the night away
it's almost as if the outcome of an uber
ride is determined by the flip of a coin
it's either easy breezy or kind of a
disaster
in stuber it's the latter only it's the
driver who's subject to all sorts of
unforeseen troubles
helmed by future man and take me home
tonight director michael daus
stuber centers on an unsuspecting uber
driver named stu
played by kumail nanjiani who picks up
his rider vic
played by dave bautista a detective
who's chasing down a dangerous terrorist
chaos ensues when stu gets tangled in
vic's dangerous ordeal and tries to keep
his nerves level himself alive
and his coveted five-star rating intact
accept the ride stuber
is offering when it hits theaters on
july 12th
love him or hate him quentin tarantino
is one of the most interesting living
filmmakers
and he's coming out with a new movie on
july 26th after making two straight
movies set in the old west once upon a
time
in hollywood is harkening back to ground
the director last covered in pulp
fiction
once upon a time is still a period piece
though this one
set in the wild year of 1969 the story
will focus on an out-of-work tv actor
played by leonardo dicaprio who's
looking to step away from show business
his sidekick and stunt double cliff
booth played by brad pitt is feeling the
same way
their journey will intersect somehow
with the manson family murders
with the notorious killing said to serve
as a backdrop of sorts to the main story
if the concept isn't enticing enough
then you might be interested in the
movie's dazzling cast
in addition to pitt dicaprio and margot
robbie as the doomed sharon tate the
movie also features appearances from
james marsden dakota fanning damian
lewis
timothy oliphant bert reynolds and al
pacino among others
and that's just a small sample the movie
will also feature the return of previous
collaborators kurt russell
michael madsen and tim roth tarantino
has long contended that he plans to
retire from filmmaking after 10 movies
whether that turns out being true or not
it sounds like movie number 9 has
everyone in hollywood wanting to be a
part of it the fast and the furious
franchise is taking a year off in 2019
it kind of
the summer we'll see the first spin-off
in the vehicular mayhem franchise this
time focusing on dwayne johnson and
jason statham's characters
luke hobbs and deckard shaw the movie
comes from a script from chris morgan
who's been with the franchise since
tokyo drift
and promises to team up the two fan
favorite characters in what sounds like
the odd couple on steroids
the movie is directed by john wick and
deadpool 2 helmer david leach
who has us hoping for both elegant
action and some biting wit
idris elba being on board to play the
movie's main villain is just the cherry
on top
the spin-off kicks off august 2nd and
can't get here fast enough
who the hell are you bad guy
august 2nd will also see the release of
new mutants
a comic book horror hybrid directed by
josh boone
splintering off from the main x-men
narrative new mutants will introduce a
group of super-powered teens who are
forced to reconcile their powers and
past sins
after they're captured and held in a
mysterious secret facility
the new mutants on deck to appear
include sunspot who can turn into a ball
of dangerous uv radiation
mirage a spooky soothsayer and a
shape-shifting robot named warlock
the cast includes maisie williams from
game of thrones charlie heaton from
stranger things
and anya taylor joy from the witch glass
and split
the movie has reportedly been through
reshoots allegedly to both add a whole
new character and make the movie scarier
whatever the real reasons behind the
pushback the film still looks
interesting
and will hopefully bring something new
to the crowded superhero genre as the
summer draws to a close
millions of readers around the world are
familiar with owen colfer's artemis fowl
novels which followed a precocious
criminal mastermind over a series of
globe crowding adventures
the fantasy series has always seemed to
write for the big screen treatment but
for whatever reason
an adaptation never took off until now
walt disney's cinematic take on the
first two books is being directed by
kenneth branagh
known to mainstream audiences for his
work directing thor and murder on the
orient express
and that time he showed up in harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
the lead role is set to be played by
irish newcomer ferdi asha with judy
dench playing a gender-swapped version
of the book's commander root
with such a beloved book property the
pressure's on to make fans happy
we'll see if the filmmakers pull it off
when the movie is released on august 9th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]